when it comes to action movies
underworld is the gothic horror
franchise that can't seem to rest in
peace
but if more sequels are on the way the
series leading lady won't be coming
along
let's take a look at why kate beckinsale
won't be back for more underworld
as it crashed into cinemas at the tail
end of 2003's summer movie season
underworld vividly reimagined what
vampire fiction could be
by positioning its blood-sucking beasts
square in the middle of a full-blown
action epic
in the process it made a legit action
superstar out of actress kate beckinsale
perhaps more surprisingly underworld
launched the vampires vs werewolves
franchise the cinematic world
never knew it needed and essentially put
low budget genre studio screen gems on
the hollywood map
to date screen gems and their partners
at lakeshore entertainment have produced
three sequels and one prequel for their
flagship franchise
and kate beckinsale has appeared as
death dealer celine in every single one
of them
the most recent underworld flick
subtitled blood wars
hit theaters in 2016 and wasn't
particularly well received by either
critics or audiences
that sort of performance rarely means
great things for a movie series and to
further complicate the underworld
producers potential dreams of celine's
future adventures it appears that
beckinsale has joined the ranks of
people who don't want anything to do
with the franchise
in a 2018 variety interview the actress
gave some candid remarks about certain
roles she'd passed or
it turns out had left behind when asked
about the possibility of making another
underworld movie she was blunt
i wouldn't return i've done plenty of
those even by hollywood standards that
curt response doesn't leave much wiggle
room for future appearances
i have seen so much war
so much killing i cannot bear more
if you're among the few underworld fans
who actually bought a ticket and
experienced blood wars and theaters
you probably aren't too heartbroken over
beckon sales outright dismissal
after all blood wars really was a bit of
a mess and its less than enthusiastic
reviews are enough to give an impression
that the franchise itself
might feel a bit long in the fang while
beckinsale didn't really address why
she's ready to move on from underworld
for good
it's a reasonably safe bet that she's
grown as weary of the franchise's
neo-gothic escapades as critics and
viewers
seem to have that's hardly a surprise
given that the actor was never really
the blockbuster franchise sort
it's easy to forget but beckinsale
actually came up in showbiz on the
strength of her work in smaller skilled
projects
like much ado about nothing the golden
bowl and laurel canyon
in the years since her underworld
breakout beckon sale has continued
to dip her toe in the indie cinema pool
every once in a while
balancing these projects with larger
scale fare like click
for instance beckon sales 2016 reunion
with her the last days of disco director
whit stillman for the tragically
underrated period peace
love and friendship earned rave reviews
and came out the same year as underworld
blood wars
which career path would you choose oh i
can't decide
for a 2017 interview with yahoo while
addressing the rumors of her playing
wonder woman beckinsale acknowledged
that part of why she passed on the role
was out of a desire not to appear in
princess diana's famously short-skirted
outfit
and embarrass her daughter in her
statement beckensale clearly addressed
her underworld getup as well i don't
know if i was desperate to be in a
leotard
i'd already done the rubber trousers you
have to take in that you have a child at
some point and how much could you
possibly embarrass them
it would seem then that kate beckinsale
wasn't too keen on those rubber trousers
throughout her underworld tenure
whether or not the thought of squeezing
back into that skin tight ensemble
another time
fueled beckinsale's decision to leave
the franchise for good remains a mystery
but it sounds like the pants may have
factored into the process
whatever the reason behind beckensale's
decision to leave the underworld
franchise is
one thing is certain it definitely isn't
because she's feeling too old for action
roles
in a 2020 interview with women's health
the then 46 year old actress discussed
her healthy diet
her action star worthy fitness regime
and her 2021
amazon prime video action movie jolt it
can feel like
a little bit of a political act to be a
woman over 32 who's having any fun at
all
and by that i don't mean doing drugs and
drinking and partying because i never am
but being goofy and going out it somehow
seems to be risque
which is just ridiculous to me and i
witness men constantly doing whatever
they like whether that's in
relationships
or deciding to buy a motorbike or
getting a tattoo
perhaps not entirely coincidentally jolt
turns this concept on its head
beckensale plays lindy a former bouncer
with violent impulse control issues
i explain it's this woman who's got this
rage disorder and every single woman has
said oh
me women are really angry right now
kate beckinsale's recent and upcoming
filmography makes her star making role
as celine
seem like the odd one out in her resume
the actress seems to be building on the
critical success of love and friendship
and focusing on projects like the
coming-of-age drama farming
and the amazon prime original mystery
drama the widow
according to deadline one of
beckinsale's more interesting upcoming
projects is director catherine
hardwick's prisoner's daughter which
will be about generational family trauma
and
the long road to healing in other words
it's going to be about as far from
vampire action movies as you can get
perhaps this is the ultimate reason
beckon sale won't return for underworld
6
she simply wants to star in projects
like these instead beckinsale clearly
has much to give on the acting front and
let's face it
five movies of stunts in a skin-tight
costume is plenty for anyone
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one